economía en directo américa de france 24
nuevamente en el estudio daniel hablando
andan y seguimos entonces con nuestra
tónica del programa del día de hoy
dedicarle gran parte a la lectura de lo
que fue esta primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales francesas
vamos entonces a dar un repaso por la
economía de ese país por supuesto claro
que sí y raúl pues que es la segunda
economía además de europa después de
alemania y que en 2021 creció un 7% este
fue su mayor aumento anual en medio
siglo después de haber pasado un muy mal
22 por culpa de la pandemia del corona
vi dos cerros además francia marzo con
un desempleo del 7,9 por ciento esto es
relativamente bajo si se compara con
otros países de la unión europea como
grecia o españa que duplican esa tasa
más del 15 por ciento 13 por ciento hoy
la desocupación en francia es la más
baja desde el comienzo de la crisis
financiera mundial de 2008 y también
tienen una deuda pública que supera al
112 como el 9% del pib quiere decir que
es más lo que debe que lo que le entra a
su casa y todo debido también a la
pandemia empecemos a repasar entonces
las propuestas de los candidatos sobre
el empleo bueno pues se manuel macro en
apunta al pleno empleo que lo define el
mismo como una tasa de desempleo de
menos del 5% quiere conseguirlo animando
a la gente a volver al trabajo por lo
que además de ofrecer incentivos
fiscales también busca dificultar que la
gente acceda a la prestación por
desempleo y si nos vamos del otro lado
con manning lepe por su parte propone
cheques mensuales de formación laboral
de 200 a 300 euros para los aprendices y
tiene además audaces propuestas de
desgravación fiscal para los
trabajadores jóvenes que tienen como
objetivo alentarlos a permanecer en
francia y que decimos el curso de la
vida ni el costo de la vida que han sido
bien clave para esta elección porque se
ha venido incrementando estrepitosamente
no solamente en francia también en
europa y en todo el resto del mundo
primero por la pandemia ahora por la
guerra en ucrania la inflación en marzo
de 2022 interanual fue del 5,1 por
ciento interanual quiere decir frente a
marzo del año pasado esto impulsado por
los costos de la energía que repuntaron
casi en un 30% y los de los alimentos
que subieron cerca del 3% y vamos a
hablar entonces de las polémicas
pensiones de materia de pensiones que
dicen los candidatos bueno hay
propuestas distintas de lado y lado del
presidente candidato macrón a pesar de
que quiere elevar la pensión mínima
mensual su monto también ha propuesto
elevar gradualmente la edad de pensión
de 62 años actuales a 65 también quiere
eliminar los regímenes especiales para
los que estén llegando al mercado
laboral mientras que su contrincante el
epen propone anclar las pensiones a la
inflación y disminuir la edad de
jubilación a 60 años para algunas
personas aquellos que apenas están
comenzando su vida laboral y estas
elecciones también dejaron a la luz los
problemas económicos de todos los
partidos tradicionales calificados
también como los grandes perdedores de
la jornada de ayer la de los grandes
perdedores porque en francia aquel
partido que no alcance el umbral del 5%
de votación no tiene derecho al
desembolso de los gastos de campaña así
que la pérdida no solamente en votación
sino también con este buen caso de los
partidos entonces tradicionales el
republicano y el socialista que
fracasaron en esta primera vuelta
electoral por un lado han hidalgo del
partido socialista tuvo menos del 2% de
los votos esto es un mínimo histórico
para el partido que ayudó a françois
hollande a ganar las elecciones del 2012
por otra parte la conservadora del
partido republicano valérie pécresse
obtuvo menos del 5 por ciento y eso
lanzó por eso hizo un llamado
desesperado para conseguir donaciones
urgentes que le permitan afrontar los
millones de euros que gastó en la
campaña y que tan grave entonces es esta
situación para el partido de
centroderecha lo describe ya mismo a la
candidata quien calificó la situación en
su cuenta de 'twitter' como crítica pues
a su partido le faltan 7 millones de
euros incluidos 5 millones que dice
haber tomado prestados ella misma
personalmente y añadió que de eso
depende la supervivencia de la derecha
republicana de todas las donaciones que
se reciban atendiendo a este llamado
pues ella o aleja y pegue sera candidata
más rica de los 12 que se presentaban a
estas elecciones presidenciales hay un
informe de la autoridad para la
transparencia de la vida pública a la
que tenían que declarar todos su
patrimonio y este reporta que ella tiene
una fortuna de cerca de 10 millones de
euros indicadores económicos como están
desde el mercado reaccionó
favorablemente a las elecciones del
domingo aunque con tímidas variaciones
el índice principal de la bolsa de parís
el cac-40 subía alrededor del 0,8 por
ciento a media jornada y el euro se
valorizaba también a media jornada un
0.4 por ciento frente al dólar y también
el rendimiento de los bonos franceses se
fortaleció los buenos son los papeles
que emite el gobierno por los que
reciben los inversionistas un interés
así están y muchísimas gracias entonces
por toda la información económica el día
de hoy volcada por supuesto a francia
por esta primera vuelta de las
presidenciales precisamente nos vamos
directo hasta parís para seguir hablando
sobre esto hacia dónde van los
candidatos y qué pasó ayer lo vamos a
saber con erika y natalia